is this undertale yes it is oh hey
Little Italy delete if anybody watching
we're not ready at everybody just hold
on to your horses we'll be right with
you
hold on to your unicorn hey alright
anyway we're still getting things ready
we were not we were very busy today
we've been very busy for a while well to
be honest I mean the carpet changed yeah
and see it but yeah we finally pulled up
all the plastic when they installed it
they we still had like construction
people coming in and out of our building
so they put down its plastic so they
wouldn't get their muddy work boots all
over it and we finally pulled it up
it's so nice except for the stain where
the carpet or the covering yeah like a
plastic roof this doesn't matter Danny
you guys can support us it's our life so
we need to talk about it a whole group
in the plasma so they're just like like
like stains of dark brown or just like
[ __ ] stains they're not brown they're
like gray
they're pretty Brown well and then
there's some chica hair around cuz she
gets so excited we're gonna bring her to
the off oh my god she goes nuts I don't
take I don't get her out of the house
enough like I need to take her for more
regular walks cuz I am NOT good about
that I'm a bad dog daddy everyone can
say I'm a bad dog daddy I mean I play
with her I played it in flip the play
the crap out of her every day but just I
I I'm not a good don't look at me like
that I'm like the crap out of her a
latex eat her up it's like a food crap
she got right up to her butt get it and
I play the crap out of her
don't question me I know what I'm doing
alright so we're still
oh yeah the game's up and you guys
should be here but before that we are
going to talk about the new videos oh
yeah yeah absolutely
um well we we've been doing something
new how does it say offline oh that's
that's a different that's a different
dream turns like but we're all nine whoa
okay alright so we should be yeah this
is like a minute something is assam
breaking in our ever-growing pile of
trash keeps collapsing in on itself all
this guy becomes so happy every box
we've ever opened is like piling it
there do lays the dumpsters so far away
I don't put movie so we just kill it
pile up like a booby one we're gonna go
buy a wheelbarrow girl you'll be my
wheelbarrow we used to do wheelbarrow
races we use a wheel barrel every
evening when we were having to it's
about success is what he's getting at
yes it's true Raja's wrestling was a fun
time all right so anyway who are we
talking we were talking about something
we're talking about the new video yeah
that we've gotten so excited yes my god
it has been the most fun I've ever had
making videos since I started doing
YouTube in fact like it's it's been that
big of a deal for us uh timewise it's
been crazy but man I am so happy
to have been able to get out and do
those things it's just I've been gushing
about it for like the past few Alek days
green eyes you're like our hours no days
whatever it is it worries about editing
yeah oh my god I moved Italy it was like
a full-on you I don't know how to
pronounce it but Gero Gero Gero gyro
Dreams of Sushi you know but that one
euro hero dreams of shoes names hero
you know I don't think it's ero someone
will someone will correct me in a sassy
way I know very soon but hey it was full
on that movie because I was legitimately
last night dreaming about the last video
that we did we licked spear apparently
it's not leaked spirits licked spear
nicked slick spear it slips beer which
means light spear in German hey probably
but yeah I was dreaming about that last
night and I woke up super early in and
if you guys remember me talking about
like my first time doing YouTube and my
first time doing all this stuff like I
would get up at ungodly hours of the
morning and then stay up until way too
late just because I was so excited about
making videos and that is how this past
week has been like we haven't gone to
but until like midnight or later yeah
midnight or later and that mantasy not
seem like a much to you guys but we've
been getting up at 7 a.m. every day as
well so well technically we're waking up
at like 6:00 6:30 that is true yeah and
it's true this morning I didn't even
need to but I got up at 6:30 but it's
just been like this I always talk about
this fire and passion that burns in your
heart for what you want to do and like I
didn't even realize that it had gone out
a bit for me and that's a sad thing to
say but it's like kind of true because I
just been doing let's play so long and
I've been like keeping it going and
interesting with like challenge videos
and sketches every once in a while
but like this just hit such a profound
target in me and if the response is
amazing all like my god and I'm so like
ecstatic with everything because this
all started with disco discomfort okay i
will get to undertale real soon but i
like i will explode if i can't talk
about this um it all started with disco
discomfort because the funny story about
that is that let's play i recorded that
like three weeks ago forever forever ago
like three weeks ago a time to order
them oh yeah the everyone was like
looking at the outfits i was like
they've been sitting in my living room
for like three weeks try it i don't know
i don't know what to do but uh so we uh
I recorded that three weeks ago and then
when I walked out of the recording room
I went over to Tyler and I was like I
have a really cool idea what if we go
out in public and find fans and dance
with them and that was literally the
only idea that was it and then we built
off of it yeah as the week's progressed
slowly and when Ethan came out yeah over
there editing right now yeah um and
checking on the stream we sound good
we're doing good okay um when Ethan came
out here we were able to refine more
ideas and be able to do so much more
yeah and we're so excited for so many
other ideas that we have coming up yeah
it's just it's just it's been a bit of a
time crunch this week and we know like
we're aware that videos have been sparse
like we know that we were fully aware of
it but just uh because we did not we
went into this week without planning
ahead like everyday well what happened
is I recorded all the let's play stuff
at the beginning of this week and then
we came up with ideas but we have other
things that we're doing we're like
working out regularly now we're going
rock climbing like twice a week we're
working out three times a week we got
trying to still get Ethan said oh yeah
Ethan is new to LA so we're trying to
get in him in here without like it
him with too much work and he's been
such a great help here
don't get an ego you don't get sappy
okay back to work
[Music]
so anyway yeah it's been it's been a
busy week this week in particular but
that doesn't mean that we haven't been
unbelievably excited to be doing these
videos and I am just like tickled to
death at the response of it when I I
can't remember who said it but someone
said that these videos were like a lot
of people said these videos were like
reminded them of the reason they
subscribe to my channel and that like I
was like oh oh oh no oh my art oh geez
Alex oh plus it's the first one we made
it was like when we were editing it mark
just got into it and got extremely
excited like this is what he always
dreamed yeah it was like it was the
moment where I realized that I could
combine everything that I've learned
about YouTube videos into one video and
make it something cohesive and
interesting and entertaining and like
it's I can't gush about it enough and I
know I know I get it yeah I know fully
well but like it's just it's it's new
and like it's to some people it's like
regularly like I we know it's been a
very busy weekend doing one video days
like the only thing we could have
possibly done to keep up with it and
still do this new thing and explore this
territory so I will say we are learning
and we're gonna find the process to make
it go quicker yeah exactly so we're
getting on that and I will stop gushing
about it we
can get to the game right about now but
it's just scootch that way just the
school just just litter just together so
yeah it is it is just oh man it's just
so exciting
like I can't overstate my satisfaction
about what we're doing so I will stop
without further ado out for the day
welcome back to undertale part 5 what
did we just leave off without the room I
water mine it's all her it's so far well
chop chop thank you so my people are
waiting for undertale thank you my
goodness we've been playing for 413
minutes anyway okay did we never leave I
don't know if we leave what I don't
think we never left it open so we left
off when you defeated yourself
oh yeah cuz the MS is exactly me so
we're gonna be doing a chill stream
we've been looking forward to the stream
all week just because we've been wanting
to talk about everything that we've been
doing this whole time and undertale is
actually a pretty good game to do that
over and also I want to do streams more
regularly so like in the end I I was
saying to die with just a little bit ago
that I miss the old style of Let's Plays
and stuff like that where where it was
less about like fancy editing and it was
less about like stupid jokes and whatnot
it was more about the game and that's
weird of me to say considering we be
making these videos with all this
editing and weird stuff but at the same
time it's like it because I've been
reminiscing about everything that we
have been doing it's just been like
bringing back all these old feelings of
like back when you first started yeah
exactly like back when I first was doing
YouTube in fact when I was first just
playing Let's Plays move OH
and it was a tarp and it was a Pinker's
that mauve I still don't know what mob
is I remember MA from Hey Arnold with
the mall Avenger who is that
Oh spider ah welcome to our parlor
dearie interested in some spider
pastries Oh
all proceeds go to real spiders if we
don't buy it from her is she gonna eat
us looks like some sort of powerful
bracelet wait
this is croissant oh well then I have no
idea
it's a spider doughnut it looks more
rubbery than usual Oh spider bake sale
all proceeds go to real spiders do we
still have the spider stuff no no I mean
you didn't think we eat it no we didn't
need it that would have been too
importantly we ate the candy but not the
spider stuff do I need to send the moss
what if I go get it is that gonna do
anything to this I have no idea this is
this is like us just exploring here just
like the location where wasn't uh wait
Italy in the dimensional box you're
right oh good call good call dimensional
max a minor ciders I don't know butter
centers bar don't know we do have the
things oh yeah alrighty then let's see
if it shows absolutely anything what if
we have to eat it in front of them which
is like no our babies you made all of
our spider babies oh all the eggs only
eggs
how could you the silk felt so pathetic
both offal psyllium nicely first he's
got a real spider well that did I think
maybe you can only buy them
oh no that's it that's where you buy oh
man nein what
I think she's she's she's in it for
herself
I don't like dying donut uh I didn't
want but that girl even though I don't
know she can't stand me and this creepy
way and looking at loose I told you if
you didn't buy anything she'd eat you I
did say that just now you scared me no
I'm not a cash well uh if I try to leave
with me let's try let's do that all
righty then oh okay there's gonna be
something to this then it can't just be
nine thousand gold doughnuts there's got
to be something here I don't want you
wait and we don't need to heal cuz for
full health so what like an event from
all right fine
Oh maybe if I call papyrus he'll be able
to tell us what do oh that's good I I'm
full of good ideas you have no idea how
many bill it wait check out the Webster
make purchase okay hey
it might sound weird that spiders need
donations but think about it they have
eight feet that's four pairs of shoes a
spider wearing four pairs of pink
booties meditate on this image medic
meditate that did nothing for us maybe
there's absolutely no reason to do that
yet maybe we should just go we should
just go okey-dokey then
ring oh yeah remember it was like a very
timid you know did the same exactly hi
oh he's here that's not what it was your
shoe I'm a fool I don't remember how to
do it that's okay
have you been so busy doing some of the
other thing huh Alfie's here this room
is like the room we saw before before
there are two puzzles to the north there
you go you have to solve them birth to
proceed
also I'd like to say I don't really like
giving away puzzle solutions but but if
you need help just call me okay actually
wait I have an idea let's be friends on
under net No then you can just ping me
when you need help no wait we're already
friends oh yes I signed you up
you've been reading in my post all time
yeah I hope you agree with me about me
Mewtwo you still know that be glasses
[ __ ]
dang it man I just said [ __ ] on the
livestream Oh Tom I mean go ahead I'm
[ __ ] care man so blink blink blink
I'm a badass let me do that step
go you should have went up there you
didn't even go back and go up how can I
go up go down go right right
go up go up left okay I had it you
didn't let me have it I had oh crap oh
no it's young it's too thin to the plane
your brain what I don't know too soon to
the plane it's Japanese pronunciations
too soon did it too soon to the plane
how offensive are you that's not at all
the Japanese production of it it's sooo
dead II see that opening something like
that I have no idea I don't know all
right whatever
what are we supposed to do oh we were
switching raising the temperature
encouraged and then God I'm not gonna be
able to dodge this crap why don't you go
Stuart Lynne in too late oh my goodness
of nice alright so is he good spare yeah
you did bacca bacca this the planes the
one that ah I have to get close to but
not not money well statute it see
approach hey it's the one that likes you
but doesn't like you how we would move
to do okay
happening goodbye I should stab them why
is a plane here on this hot air this
makes absolutely no sense
how is this a full plane why is a
monster plane what does that say about
the technology of the period where the
humans come from it's a full plane right
and we can assume that everything in
this game is not an inside joke and
everything must be canon right it's a
plane and and it can't just make up what
a plane is it has to know right they
have cell phones so our airplanes living
monsters no that's not where you're
gonna not it not at all okay okay so oh
it's the alien thing only one shot at
this okay all right it's gonna go back
oh [ __ ] up not if you don't know
anything about me screwing up I know
things are going to scream
dagnabbit
yeah great when you have two shots right
not one this one only has one shot so
there must be go down okay now go over
yeah hang on my knees Arista no no no no
no no oh oh ye of little faith
Oh oh ye of little faith
ah see you have no faith in me as
condition as my favourite movie says to
schedule stay out of my swamp
skadoosh and augers are like onions
Scottish anyway skadoosh Scotty was
Scottish my fav medicine won't you be
the other my fav med at any moment right
when everything looks the baddest he
poses dramatically like when he's on a
cooking show and the eggs don't turn
ever head my fav mettaton moment he's
money he beats up then he'll turn until
even if it's turn what's supposed to be
a quiz show
Wow why today she wasn't like characters
appeared like so frequently I honestly
have no idea okay I gotta go
is funny
everybody forgive but it oh nice thanks
man
I'm going to be the best wool oh there's
two puzzles probably one at the bottom
hottest you should finish like like my
favorite favorite favorite favorite 3d
anime I'm making waffles kaduche you
know you know you know maybe I'm trying
for time
isn't doing in the garden ah come on
all just a movie okay i got rekked on
them what
oh yeah the orange you didn't see what I
thought
no bluest blue sit still for did I did
sit through it it just it still blasted
me anyway [ __ ] hey this um doesn't
have anything to do with guiding you but
sorry hey do you want to watch a human
TV show we gonna have to take his human
TV shows kinda drilled out of the cave
it's called mu nu kisi QT hold whose
line is it anyway I'm sure about this
net on um well that's okay Oh alpha Pi
was dead just thought I'd ask
just thought I I think you'd really like
it if you gave it a chance I don't know
about that new Miu kissa cutie oh boy do
I have one shot of this corner shop all
right you ready for the ultimate oh you
had
that you just had it no yes go down down
no no no no up up down left right right
ah this guy's we doesn't want to keep
you around this guy right here he's good
good job that guy you're that guy I'm
not gonna do that guy we you stopped to
smell the flowers what
[Music]
trying to say I don't know buddy yellow
they are yellow mm you know but I'm
young words huh are you trying to say
I don't know you racist white okay yay
we dead well I adore the two green keys
drunk ears ring smell of cobwebs fill
the air your field determination Oh
the spider entrance we need the spider
donut here okay so if I were to say oh
no the signals clue what is it Clark a
bug is so it's a lot of spidery stuff so
that's how my designer inspired me with
this who's that hi let's put it in the
box way I'm gonna see what it is first
item
heck is this the meat is made of
something called water sauce oh yeah
didn't we buy it from that one dude
there's this the one that songs gave my
limo and sons goodness I have no idea
but we don't we need to empty your heart
all right stuff here a bit instant
noodles old - - we don't need the old -
- anymore hot dog can go maybe we need
that I don't know what the others are so
noodles for well it's probably just food
right as the heels comes with everything
you need to equip me yes just just just
put that box I'm gonna keep it just good
cuz I don't really want to eat any of
this other stuff we're gonna find out
spiders are you going into the school
whatever you do what happen if this is
deep
oh jeez oh jeez don't you think you've
done it delete you've done it oldest
fight oh oh oh oh
did you hear what they just said no
bunnies bunnies boulders they said a
human wearing a striped shirt will come
through okay that sounds like me only in
school I heard that they hate spiders
we're gonna eat spiders and get them to
really hate us now when I get it whoo I
heard that they love to stomp on them oh
we're moving so slow yep I heard that
they like to tear their legs up well
that's not true at all yeah I heard oh
hey ah hello it's that that they're all
we were good they're awfully stingy with
their money I told you she was evil yeah
well I mean I was a horrible evil spider
lady you think your taste is too refined
for our pages don't you dearie
oh I disagree with that notion I think
your taste is exactly what this next bag
needs but I have I have I have a spider
donut
maybe we often never even heard of this
person Oh Little Miss Muffet et cetera
tuffet eating her curds and whey Ohan
along came a spider who sat by the cider
oddly the way I remembered it too just
like you did I said the exact same words
anyway what what do we do about the
spider cider dang it oh that's not what
I did
Oh where'd you get that
did you steal it oh my pet it's time to
show them what we do with thieves Oh
telegram yeah I didn't even get your
experiences battle they're saying that
they saw you and you were really
passionate about spiders oh my this is
all been a big misunderstanding
why didn't even get to experience the
brunt of this battle I didn't even give
this computer take a sassy dialog I
didn't get to even be eaten by a spider
which is always my dream Tyler what's
the one thing you've known me for years
now what's the one thing I've always
said about what I want in life
Debra her yes but good eaten by a spider
I've been saying and since I was a child
I mean it's still better than a way to
when he dies wants to be eaten by us did
you not know this he wants to be a
simple one miss if he wants his ashes
but in oosoo sorry wait it ruined your
secret was it I don't know not anymore
oh boy Wow bird that I've never been
[ __ ] hard time never
maybe ass but maybe I blocked it out
alright Alana's press oh the person who
asked for that soul they must have meant
a different human in this driveshaft
sorry for all the trouble I'll make it
up to you you can come back here anytime
and for no charge at all I'll wrap you
up and let you blow play with my well I
didn't lose the pair didn't see I ruined
it I've ruined good Eileen that just oh
okay
I thought I was gonna be a pirate yeah
damn it I got missed out I'm being
wrapped up in a cocoon burrito I'll spin
Muffet is sparing you this is when you
the kill ah well maybe now I can
actually check muffin she invites you to
her parlor excuse yourself what are you
doing
I don't know struggle oh goodness he's
trying to escape the web nothing happens
it's time to go oh let's see
hey tango huh refuses your money take my
damn money
feeling comfortable trapped in that web
this bunch of crap huh little man
keeping you here you don't mind being
gobbled up I don't mind oh I don't mind
just kidding of course who are you hmm
well maybe bond is neither all the stuff
clap oh boy in so thinking of a spider
devouring if you alive is just
salivating at heart no no it's time
together or is it mr. tempting is gonna
be no dot downloaded look at all my look
at all my blood in my body
whoever blood green
we're now it's down to five gold Tama do
money
timid your morning it's just the dawn
it's over
whoa pours you a cup of spiders that's
food this is a bunch of crap all right
fine you know what we've been the spider
dance I think that's what that is is you
knew a spider dance is that your spider
dance my spider game okay we're done
here
you won she dad later oh it's gonna say
look at her eyes I'm not shot but look
at her ass I said I is gonna spite a big
spider blast but a booty got a big
thorax on air or cor blimey
I shall pay for that on our Scott do my
favorite 3d anime Crocodile Dundee in
traction oh no I gotta check it out
donkey skidding she's good
kung fu Crocodile Dundee oh that was fun
see again do it already then Turtles
you're gonna be sorry
oh no just lay there twitching when she
let's me go I'm like stuck as yeah oh
please seven years later the corpse of
fun by the next child that walks free
anyway at least we found out what those
were for yes we finally did two poster
for medicines latest stage performance a
tragic tale of two star-crossed lovers
kept apart but the tides of fate looks
like it's almost time for the
performance Oh Oh should I go back and
save you think there's a save point on
the car what are the odds is a save
point on the other side of this
generally pretty good cuz that's like a
boss battle but maybe it's thinking that
you would be not stupid enough to not go
back I'm gonna go back just in case just
a smidgeon case da so it will we love hi
hello there you are Deary
you're always welcome in my parlor to
stay on your best behavior that's the
only way that I know that I would laugh
would be I still I don't think we're
ever gonna laugh as hard as we did when
we were shooting earlier today oh oh we
were shooting uh I can talk about this
right yeah it's up to you to be a little
little preview uh tomorrow I'll just say
tomorrow is going to be a yandere
simulator themed a thing or it's so good
we bought those pictures you saw we had
matching outfits for everybody it's
going to be wonderful when we get them
and oh that looks so good
oh yeah he's working on like right now
it looks really good
Katherine's working over on the other
screen too she doesn't have time for our
[ __ ] she's even that was a test you
should not look back here alright yeah
but so they're helping out over there
while we're doing this live stream and
but the other thing we recorded was I
recorded the insult generator game and
so what we did was we basically made a
little sketch where we sat down across
from her table and we did a look at
roast of each other
and it got so real so real so real to
yourself sure see oh
hilarious and I remember back in the day
oh geez alright see there wasn't a save
point it's a good idea we won yes
oh gosh uhmm let me that medicine in
medicine oh yeah could it be so my one
true love
oh Jesus oh oh hi I'm Eddie that does
seem like something I would do
admittedly
I've worn a fair number of dresses for
some very nice japanese schoolgirl
efforts it's not I keep getting
distracted now cuz I'm watching oh oh my
love please run away I'm not gonna sang
please run away monster King forbid your
stay humans must live for God even if
it breaks my heart they brought you in
for tension even and then you'll die ha
ha ha
as I be exactly really sad you're gonna
die cry cry cry so sad is happening I
didn't quite hear the tone there so
wasn't sure forgot that right but I
think I nailed that I think he didn't I
know you're gonna alright finally
completed the circle so sad so sad that
you're going to the dungeon oh well well
toodles
ah oh this doesn't look like the dungeon
looks like everything else we're doing
oh no what oh this is rocket it looks
really weird with the dress there off
his pubes are fluttering in the wind
look I dyed my hair pink and Frizzle is
he Oh No whatever shall I do my love has
been cast away into the dungeon a
dungeon with a puzzle so dastardly my
paramour will surely perish Oh
ah the color of the horrible colored
tile maze each colored tile has its own
sadistic function for example a green
tile sounds a noise and then you must
okay I think we actually have to
remember this yes green is monster in
monster red tile it is uh oh no it's
right you remember all the electric you
bluest swim if yellow is next to water
earth blue is next to yellow it will
electrocute you yeah red is okay as far
as I remember no red you can't pass
through so green monster water is okay
but so if we wink pink is okay yeah on
you'd better hurry because if you don't
get through in 30 seconds okay we really
have to look at this so green blue green
yellow pink blue pink I think that know
what is the real yellow something about
purple sharks don't like sharks don't
like it when your sharks don't like it
when you're a thing with when you smell
like a thing so you can't go through the
water without oranges the smelly tile
something like that okay
oh you'll be incinerated by these Jets
of fire ah ha ha my poor love I'm filled
with so much grief I can't stop laughing
good luck darling
alright I think I know what I need
I think I need to watch it right okay
that's right purple makes you move
forward and then that's electricity so
we got you gotta go through yeah and
then we can go through this purple let's
go through here we can knock we gotta go
down down just move you up down this way
No
so straight down here yep through oh oh
I'm so sorry looks like you're out of
time here come the flames darling oh
they're closing in getting closer
oh my any minute now
[Music]
watch out
I'll save you I'm hacking into the
firewall right now oh cool thanks Oh No
how could this happen
boiled again by the brilliant doctor
Alfie's wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute
something right here
something I read at all Alfie's program
that robot Alfie's Alfie's designed this
whole thing to make it seem like Alfie's
is a hero yes we discussed this I
believe last time did we I think so
hmm I suddenly don't trust alvie's and I
love mettaton because he's me what what
was that can we go back no Ned smells I
didn't press a button that was like
black oh come on
mettaton give up already you'll never be
able to beat us
none as long as we work together your
puzzles over now go home and leave us
alone puzzle over
Alfie's darling what are you talking
about did you forget what the green
tiles do they make a sound then you have
to fight a monster
well darling that monster is me oh oh
wow this is the quiz thing again is it
are you sure about that I think so yeah
that's what I always do
this is it darling say goodbye hello is
that your phone you better answer it now
that's you what else
this seems bad but don't worry then
there's one last thing I installed on
your phone you see that yellow button
yeah go to this phone Zacks menu and
press it okay
my phone's act menu my item when I don't
have a phones act menu oh okay
you press the yellow button the phone is
resonating with meta tons present this
is it darling say goodbye oh whoa hey
whoa hey whoa aah
nowproceed Oh
you've defeated me how can this be you
are stronger than I thought etc whatever
okay Oh ring looks like you beaten you
did a really great job out there all
thanks to you or dot dot
um hey this might sound strange but can
I tell you something before I met you I
didn't really I didn't really like
myself very much for a long time I've
felt like a total screwup like I
couldn't do anything without without
ending letting everyone down
what guiding you has made me feel a lot
better about myself so thanks for
letting me help you
ah anyway we're almost to the core it's
just past MTT resort come on let's
finish this
okay so what's interesting here is
obviously Alfie's is constructing this
scenario in order to make you feel good
about being friends with her and I could
see that as manipulative it's definitely
manipulative no never Zen right yeah but
at the same time it is helping her her
her her it's helping her out with her
own sense of self-worth as far as we
know this could all be a clever ruse so
I'm waiting for more information at this
point with the muscular bongos oh like
we're talking taking a rain check on
that telling you thing like don't your
undying about this okay
he seems happy
Oh something else is padded like a
muscular bongo yeah I'm here hey it's
you good this is excellent hear this you
fells but oh my ice cream I'm actually
sold out ever there sorry
wait I still got something for here a
big smile
how about that oh thank man also I've
got something for you huh you better
give me something blue skiddoo she's
gonna kick you douche buddy it's gonna
do Stu you skadoosh to them skadoosh him
like muscular longer the stage I guess
we could go back and save
let's do that yeah it's not too far
anyway who might as well do that I bet
there's gonna be I said wool all right
you do this one matter time looked
really really cool in that dress it sort
of makes me feel like I could wear one
too
do you do you man don't let anybody tell
you how to live your life you are my
lady
yeah I'm fun there yes yeah that's
what's important right so I have no idea
what's next but I have a funny feeling
it's the big guy
well I have a funny feeling